start with my take on resolute a classic  Moroccan spice blend in a dry pan toast  cinnamon cloves coriander fenugreek and  fennel seeds then add mustard seeds and  cumin when the seeds start to pop  they're ready add paprika and grind into  a fine powder for the hummus peel and  chop butternut squash put on a baking  tray and add garlic simply bashed and  chopped ginger  drizzle with olive oil seasoned and  sprinkle over the spice mix  then roast in a hot oven for half an  hour inches soft allowed to cool and  place in a blender  at tahini a nutty pace made from sesame  seeds cooked chickpeas a dash of lemon  juice and a drizzle of olive oil  Flitz into a luxurious and creamy and  textured spice is toasted for maximum  flavor amazing roasted squash hummus